hello and welcome to images in video the
killer use case for cloud storage i'm
dave elliott product lead responsible
for storage here in google's cloud
platform my background is storage and
storage in the enterprise we're here
today to talk with you about some of the
unique challenges in storing and
accessing media and some innovative
solutions from google
i'm jeff kember and i'm a cloud
solutions architect i've had the
pleasure of working at different
companies such as ilm pixar frame store
and blizzard i'm here to chat with you
today about some of the media
requirements as well as different use
cases from customers
great so let's get started so today's
agenda will start with jeff sharing his
experiences in dealing with media
ensuring some key requirements for
storing and accessing video images and
audio files then i'll introduce object
storage and cloud storage and discuss
how they are well suited to media assets
next i'll briefly to talk a little bit
about google cloud storage and how it's
differentiated from other cloud object
stores and we'll finish with a few
examples of where google cloud storage
is used today
jeff want to take it absolutely dave so
i've spent most of my career dealing
with large files of disparate types and
sizes and one of the defining aspects
for me of media files is just
how how many files you you can have you
have many many small files you have very
very large files you can have files that
derive other files so if you have a
mezzanine file for instance for
streaming you'll have the entire film
and then you'll have to produce 28
different flavors of it you'll have to
make different bit rates different
resolutions different codecs for
different platforms and all of that
storage is challenging to predict in
size um more complex though is the fact
that users now have 4k cameras in their
pocket and they're shooting video um
there's applications that are running on
all the platforms that are just
ingesting a massive amount of content
and when we talk about media files we're
talking about not just video but but i
assume audio and images as well there's
a lot of similarities across all those
types of files right correct yeah so
from a media standpoint
i've been working with audio files
tons of imagery video files and various
hybrids of those different types and the
source files can be kept in multiple
versions and then recombined so you end
up having multiple versions of the
various files in different stages of
production that's one of the size growth
scalability issues guys so size growth
scalability one of the kind of defining
features of all types of media
okay great great so what else are you
seeing with meteo uh they're it's
growing it's growing rapidly so what
what how's that translate into a
requirement for storage well we made a
transition from standard f to high def
many years ago and everything is pretty
much 1080p now and moving forward though
4k has caught on in the last couple of
years we're seeing that it's not a fad
it's an actual growth trend for us
customers are paying for 4k content it's
not a fad all right not a fad
customers are also interested in hdr and
the standard will be ratified before
long that will provide even more color
depth and that basically gives you
greater film-like looks in terms of
shadow detail and brightness um the
image looks quite a bit more lifelike
than standard imagery does today so
these consume enormous amounts of
storage eyes absolutely when you go up
in resolution and then you go up in
color depth you very quickly grow the
size of the file significantly and that
is yet another type of flavor that you
need to make when you're producing a
video streaming archive for us okay okay
so growth huge issue so i assume
scalability then is a a significant
requirement when we're talking about uh
designing cloud or designing storage
architectures for media so what else is
important protection
right security is key you need to ensure
that only you have access to the data
and only the people you grant access to
have access to the specific bits of data
you want an example would be if you have
a massive data archive that is
proprietary to your company you want to
ensure that you can provide distribution
for elements of that and have great
controls over who gets at that data and
of course no one else does so access
control encryption things like that are
important when you're storing these very
very valuable assets yes what about um
what about just generally what losing
the assets what about durability
right it becomes very expensive to have
multiple copies and manage multiple
copies from a version sinking standpoint
and such so having a highly durable
single point source is lovely paying
someone else to manage that storage for
you extremely valuable when you do it
on-prem you end up having high
availability storage you have cooler
storage you have mountains of tapes that
are stored both on-prem and in cold
storage off and i imagine this is how a
lot of companies do it today so high
durability is a key requirement you you
likely and companies today likely have
multiple replicas in order to meet that
durability requirement they're often
contractually required to have three
depending on the type of work uh what
about availability how important is that
yeah availability is critical on the
project that you may be working on
having the media available to you
randomly is key if it takes you hours to
be able to pull the data back or even
days if you have to online the data from
tape and the tape may not be on premises
it takes hours to get it or up to
potentially three days to get the data
back overnight online it look at it and
realize you didn't restore enough of it
or you restored too much of it and
therefore it took too long to restore
and there's often dependencies that are
found in that restored data that then
point to other data that you then have
to repeat the process so on-demand
on-demand availability is key correct
and that was only a local restore you
know you're then in a scenario where if
some if you have a global office
elsewhere and the data is not local to
them you have to work with the time zone
of that local office to get that data
back and then ship it to where you are
or imagine a consumer that's in india
might want to listen to a music file or
someone who's in paris may want to see
an image a photograph that is stored
some rich media file asset and so the
ability to have that on-demand access
globally yes is important yeah consumers
are definitely focused on getting things
on demand and globally i mean the web
services all provide that today great
great and then you also i know you also
talk a little bit about
the importance from an availability
standpoint of just generally knowing
what the heck you have right yes i've
worked with customers who have large
vaults and i'm talking a cabinet with
hard drives in them and they'll be
handwritten post-it notes with an
elastic band around there and that's the
limit of the knowledge of the data and
they said yes the people who wrote those
notes aren't here anymore but we've
passed it down over time
and that's that's unfortunate in the
fact that how do you get at that data
you literally have to take that hard
drive and mount it in a machine that has
the correct interface and then it's
hopefully run in the right os to be able
to pull that data off and then you have
to sift through it that's a horribly
expensive task in terms of human time
and so
the question is whether or not that data
actually gets read again so the value of
that data may be really high
but the usefulness of it the value of it
though to to you the ip owner is really
low and the fact you can't get at it
because the cost is higher so a rich
metadata model might be something that
would be valuable so that you can
describe these media assets in a rich
way and be able to uh have easy access
and essentially uh better availability
to them absolutely great great okay so
we've heard um i guess to summarize what
i've heard is scalability is important
yes media files are growing
incredibly fast
flexibility so you need to be able to
support small files and large files you
need to be able to self-describe the
files or have the files described in
some way with which metadata security
protection durability
and then generally availability are
important yes yeah the global
availability is the the really the
exciting bit
it's been challenging
working in the field with multiple
offices globally and you're having to
rely on file synchronization dedicated
links multiple file systems in each of
the disparate offices that then require
synchronization
that there's a lot of overhead there's
there's multiple people required to make
sure that system works with a central
global repository you can just have
individuals access the data they need
for me that's super exciting from an
availability standpoint fantastic
fantastic so now that we've chatted some
about the interesting requirements for
storage and storing media i'd like to
touch on object storage and cloud
storage and how those fit many of the
requirements that jeff just mentioned
then i'll introduce cloud storage and
provide a brief overview of how google
cloud storage is different
so a blob store or an object store is a
storage architecture that manages data
as objects versus a storage architecture
like a file system which manages data as
a file hierarchy or block storage which
manages data as blocks within sectors or
tracks so two tenets of object storage
that make them popular choice for
managing media and media assets are
first
they're a flat flexible and scalable
system so traditional storage as i
mentioned relies on file system
hierarchies which creates certain upper
limits on scalability and performance
object storage doesn't have that
limitation as jeff mentioned scalable
performance is a critical aspect of
storing and accessing media files object
stores also provide flexibility on the
size of objects
second thing is object stores provide a
robust and flexible metadata layer
metadata capabilities as objects are
stored with the data
they also have an address and this
robust and flexible metadata so the
metabay of flexibility compared to other
types of storage addresses some of the
accessibility concerns that jeff
mentioned earlier more metadata means
better access and better control
so object storage isn't perfect it
doesn't solve all problems but it does
bring simplicity and flexibility to
access and scale for storing media files
if you understand object storage and why
it's such a popular choice i'd like to
touch a little bit now on object storage
in the cloud object storage in the cloud
adds additional benefits
such as
first
scale becomes global jeff talked about
scale and how critical it was scale
becomes global with global data centers
so the larger the cloud the more
capacity you can use to store your media
assets that may come during periods of
unpredictable growth
so google manages one of the largest
clouds in the world and supports many
many many exabytes of storage
next object storage in the cloud can be
more available so major cloud providers
provide data centers all over the globe
at google we have more than a hundred
edge locations in 33 countries data will
stay online which is a stark in stark
contrast to tape storage
also data can be accessed with simple
restful apis
third cloud storage
should be could be and likely is more
durable a well-constructed cloud will
deliver highly redundant geographically
diverse storage in the case of google
cloud storage we offer 119's durability
across all tiers of object storage
and finally a well-constructed cloud
should be even more secure while a few
years ago some people believed cloud was
less secure because they didn't manage
security themselves today i think most
people agree that a well-run cloud
provider benefits from having a very
very large and very focused team
providing security at google we've got
something like more than 600 people
whose job it is to protect our cloud
infrastructure so overall as with with
any cloud any cloud service uh much of
the heavy lifting is designed
uh is designing a durable secure
scalable cloud is outsourced so it lets
you focus on what you're doing best
would you say jeff that that those key
requirements scalability durability
availability um are some of the key
tenets that
people who are managing and
the media assets are looking for
absolutely the opportunity to be able to
get at any file anytime super valuable
the
example i can give would be
um i was on a production where we had to
get um there was a directorial change
and they needed access to a file that
never happens never happens directors
never changed their mind um
so in that context we needed to bring an
asset back online that had been moved
off of the fast storage essentially um
and the version um was you know
available but we had to we had to pull
it back and it was going to take about a
day and a half to get that data just
because another office and such so
when i moved to another firm where 100
of the data was online in terms of
archival
we were able to restore the data back in
just a couple of minutes you could just
change your shot directory go over to
where you needed to find the file and
pull it back and that emulates the exact
work use model that we have for google
cloud platform you can go and pull the
files back in just a couple of seconds
and you have access to the entire data
set so that the the cost savings on on
the several days of people time and
schedule time um wall clock as we call
it um was huge great yeah yeah i've
heard that story types of those stories
over and over again it's the
accessibility availability of the data
and then what you can do with it and the
time that you save and trying to pull
that data back is one of the key
benefits of having an object store and
having a cloud object store absolutely
when you look at the total cost of
ownership for on-premise storage in
terms of people time and the number of
days if you're on a schedule of any kind
and you have you can add up the salaries
of all the people and add that to your
total cost of overhead and every day it
takes you longer to complete it because
you're pulling storage either you're
offline or on online data to try and
find it that's all real cost great great
so
we've talked a little bit about the
requirements for
for
media and managing media files and media
assets
we then moved on to talk a little bit
about how object store is a different uh
approach that is really meets a lot of
those requirements and then how cloud
object store uh is uh is really a a
even better approach
so if you're managing media assets or if
you will in the future
um
i i guess i guess um you may ask the
question you know why google
and what's unique about google
so now i'd like to transition into how
google and google cloud storage is
different
google's had to cope with massive
amounts of data because of its grand
scale google services are truly global
generating exabytes and exabytes of data
a secret to google's continuing success
stems from the fact that google is able
to operate at this scale before anyone
else and at price points order of
magnitudes less expensive than
competitors
so as a result there are a few distinct
advantages to our scale and our
experience google cloud storage lets you
store your media assets on a global
globally available highly secure and
efficient infrastructure our object
store is differentiated in several ways
first
we deliver massive massive scalability
have i said that yet
massive scalability have i said lots and
lots of exabytes yeah many
many many many can't tell you exactly
but many many many growing rapidly we've
as much capacity as anyone needs
one customer came to us a while ago and
asked for
several hundred petabytes because they
couldn't procure storage quickly enough
and they said they were they wanted to
grow into maybe a couple of exabytes now
as a storage guy that's a lot of storage
that is an unbelievable amount of
storage and we honestly didn't have any
concerns no when they asked how many you
know if they could have an exabyte of
data we could arrogantly respond with
how many exabytes would you like yes
exactly second our global network our
global network is a huge differentiator
we've got built-in edgecast capabilities
where we keep your data on our network
as long as we possibly can and we
automatically store replicas near where
objects are most frequently requested so
this means better availability and hints
a better user experience customer
experience with your media assets our
network as i mentioned before has more
than a hundred edge locations in 33
countries for caching
and you'll be tested on this 133 keep
those numbers a quiz
and uh we're the only cloud provider
that actually has laid fiber of late
cables across both oceans so can you
talk a little bit about the use case i
have data in europe and i want to read
it in america and then i want to read it
in singapore as well can you talk a
little bit about how the buckets work
well really it comes down to you know a
key differentiator as we talk about the
as you talked about the requirements for
media assets to be global in nature
right the person in india or chicago or
singapore needing access to these right
because the work is often done in
multiple locations and delivered
elsewhere or the customer or the
customer is in multiple locations you
may be uh web serving you may be serving
out
images or or you may be serving on
videos right the customer might be in
various locations and because we have
our own network we own our network it's
one of the huge advantages we've created
uh a
uh we we um we we've been pioneers in
creating um ways to uh optimize best
optimize uh data movement uh you know
across um large uh distances so for a
customer that does have a global
operation that wants global access to
their data
that's really one of our you know key
differentiators in addition to the to
the network we also are optimized for
reading very large files so we've
optimized for server side throughput
meaning we simply
are faster in reading large files
and and this really comes from our
legacy in youtube and photos and google
play and that means that your customers
have a better experience when they use
your media the fourth reason is our
pricing it's both low and simple to
understand
we have uh frequently declining prices
as opposed to
say you know again as a storage guy
purchasing storage hardware that's got
to be capitalized over three years
and on average we're 13 to 15 lower than
our closest cloud competitor um and you
know the thing the feedback that i get
so much from customers is just much
simpler to understand
the fifth uh major thing i'll call out
for google cloud storage differentiators
is what i i'm just calling value-added
services it can be applied against your
data when it's in our cloud you know
this goes back to your accessibility uh
comment earlier jeff where you know if
you if you can uh leverage uh if you
could apply systems against um uh
services against the data you can create
more value for your customers so massive
scalability global network large read
file throughput pricing and these
value-added services which i'll let you
talk about in a couple minutes make
sense it does great
so i just briefly wanted to introduce
google cloud storage the actual service
itself we've got three flavors standard
durable reduced availability and
near-line storage uh they all come with
11 9's durability target and they
primarily differ in price and
availability standard storage offers
99.9
availability sla it's ideal for
workloads that require performance
availability and durability so it's sort
of the standard or maybe the premium one
durable reduced availability is exactly
what it says it's highly durable
and it has a slightly reduced
availability sla at 99
so it's ideal for workloads that can
accept the occasional unavailability
um for instance batch workloads
finally near line storage is our newest
storage offering and this is ideal
ideally designed as a cool storage pool
this is
only a penny a gig per month
but it comes with a penny
read penalty
per gig
and it's ideal for infrequently accessed
media such as backup files
or even archive files
so with that um jeff uh i'd like i'd
love for you to talk about that fifth
thing i mentioned on the previous slide
which was the value added services so we
talked a lot about the benefits of
moving to an object store the benefits
of moving to a cloud and benefits moving
to to google's infrastructure but where
i think a lot of excitement is today
is what can you do
with the data once it's in
the cloud once it's in our cloud
absolutely one of the really cool things
about google is the leadership and the
lead that we have in machine learning
technology it is not an overly exciting
conversation to say what does a gig cost
and hey wait hold on a second
well it can't be but for me what's more
compelling is things like the cloud
translate api that we have the ability
to have 80 plus languages available
you can put one language in auto
language detection you can get another
language out and that works across both
text as well as speech so we have a
cloud speech api and that will allow you
to have both batch as well as streaming
audio so you can as people are familiar
with talking to your phone that can be
in one language we can do a translate to
text for that we can do a a or a actual
language translation with that and using
the cloud natural language api we can
then do a context awareness of what was
said what was relevant about that and be
able to deconstruct the language and get
the sentiment of what the user is
looking for so this this sounds like a
corner case it sounds like something
that may not apply to a lot of people
but the the concept that there's this
service that's really innovative service
that you're applying now against your
data that you otherwise couldn't have
done if you're just sitting on a tape
somewhere i think that's really
compelling absolutely yeah from from an
imagery standpoint i'd encourage you to
download google photos it's free it's
available for ios and android you can
choose to compress your images a little
bit with jpeg and there's no limit on
what you can upload if you choose that
option the nice thing about it is you
can put thousands and many many
thousands of thousands of images up um
and the server on the back end will do
the metadata analysis for you so if you
type in golden gate bridge or you type
in cat or you know any of the search
terms for imagery that you may have
you'd be amazed at the accuracy and the
speed with which the imagery can be
presented to you so the the vision api
um is fantastic you can feed it a
significant amount of imagery and get
back highly relevant scored metadata and
it comes to you with a percentage of
accuracy um it includes um face
detection it includes uh emotion and um
you can decide if someone is is angry or
sad or pensive there's all sorts of
you know different complexities built in
built into the model you can show it an
image of two kittens and it'll tell you
what kind of kittens they are
it's it's a really really compelling use
case but what's interesting to me is
taking a massive multi-petabyte or
multi-hundred petabyte archive that you
may have and online that under the cloud
and then running metadata analysis
against it with the vision api that
allows you to then get at that data it
becomes cataloged
it becomes useful you're able to
monetize that and you're able to either
resell it or make it available to
consumers or make it available to your
employees in the company depending the
type of data and that's just the current
road map of what we have there's more
products coming soon
backed by our machine learning
technology we also have big query and
big data analytics
google is extremely adapted handling
large amounts of data with huge numbers
of queries per second to be able to data
mine and come up with relevant responses
on massive data sets to the queries you
have so if you have large data that you
want to work with please use our tools
they're really fantastic
in addition we also offer transcoding
for media use cases if you have images
or video that is in one format you need
it in another we offer everything from
roll your own ffmpeg solutions to fully
managed backed solutions with partners
and the transcoding use case again is
especially compelling it runs extremely
well on our per minute cloud
and the massive amount of storage we
have means you can transcode everything
in parallel and be able to deliver it
globally fantastic so these are some
good examples
of once you
move your data to the cloud you can
apply things like
machine learning
analytics you can it can
potentially apply other innovative
services that are coming from google in
the future
that really create some differentiation
based upon your data absolutely you can
also roll your own as well our open
source tensorflow product is well open
source you can download it make your own
graphs and you can run your own models
against your data as well yeah we're all
about open so if you want to run
containers locally and then run them on
data you have in the cloud
that that's fully portable great great
so so we we've talked about some of the
differentiators of gcs um and now now
let's let's take a second and dive into
or at least talk a little bit about so
how are customers actually using this i
mean who's using google cloud storage
and who's using cloud storage generally
object store you know are there are they
managing media files and and what kind
of companies are doing that great well
we have vimeo which is a
very popular video streaming service we
have snapchat for social media we have
spotify for music streaming ubisoft for
gaming we have wix for websites we have
ignite for file sharing khan academy
that everyone is familiar with some
fantastic large videos available there
in addition jdi for file sharing as well
great great so those are some some great
brand names that are using um google
cloud storage for
uh for for for storing their and
managing their media assets
so i mean with that let's talk a little
bit about um about next steps so if if
you're managing media assets or if you
will in the future
where to get started so there's several
patterns we've seen on how people get
started using google cloud storage for
managing their media assets
first serving globally so our
multi-regional geo-redundant storage
lightning fast network large file
read throughput performance and scale
make gcs an ideal storage pool for
serving media files
second transcoding transcoding and data
processing so our regional dra ability
to burst workloads again our global
network our envato services make this
great for some of the services that jeff
mentioned earlier layering on top of
your media files
and third archiving a disaster recovery
so
with low predictable price including no
ingress fees consistent set of apis
across all three tiers and an instant
on-demand access make this an ideal
service for archiving and disaster
recovery that's an excellent point with
nearline we've we've reduced the latency
down so it's it's incredibly quick it's
it's under a second uh for read and
we've also removed the throttling on
egress so the larger the size of pipe
you have the more quickly obviously we
can send the data to you and that high
predictability allows you to know what
it would cost if you want to bring back
400 terabytes of data you know how long
it'll take and you know what it'll cost
and that's really important in a dr
scenario that you're exactly right it's
not just a question of a low of low
price or low cost of storing uh your
assets for a long period of time but the
fact that you have predictability on on
recovery is a key aspect that customers
seem to really like
so with that i'm going to wrap up um if
you're managing media if you're managing
media assets cloud storage google cloud
storage offers you a low-cost solution
that can scale scale scale lets you
focus on what you do best to
differentiate your business
the great thing about cloud is it's easy
to try i recommend the try train and
engage process information is plentiful
online and we're here to help you be
successful thanks for joining us today
thanks for watching
you